du gâchis qui n'est pas truqué va
désigner deux personnes autour de la
table qui vont avoir une limitation à
faire c'est parti faites péter la
roulette on va voir les deux premiers
pour cette première battle limitation
c'est parti on y va liane foly qui doit
faire muriel robin et vincent moscato
patrick timsit
alors on va démarrer par bientôt libre
et leurs bas et vous passez aux mosquées
toi l'air très content le travail on
arrive vers toi j'avais dû bosser sait
jamais si je mens je vais arriver à
faire quelque chose se passe aussi bien
vas-y c'est parti alors je me disais
j'avais envie de raconter une blague
vas-y voilà la bombarde et vos camarades
en face un jour des blagues très très
très crus web veut dire qu cru vrai nom
alors c'est dans la jungle c'est un
chimpanzé
il est très très très très fatiguée à et
puis à comme moi d'ailleurs il est crevé
il crevait sa soirée et alors y vivent y
croise son ami l'éléphant qui lui dit
dit non tu as l'air crever toi qu'est ce
que tu as fait mais qu'est ce que tu as
fait n 8 à la crevette encore bge et
haguenau avait dit non non non non
j'étais avec sophie la girafe
elle me disait embrasse-moi échoit le
cul voilà tout simplement je l'avais ben
c'est vrai mais quand elle le fait c'est
plus familial
vincent moscato ce que tu peux nous
faire patrick timsit ceci muriel robin
traitants salut c'est titi patrick allez
on va continuer la bataille d'imitation
la deuxième place sur yan tu as gagné
haut la main la première titoff si
délicate
c'est plutôt et carole rousseau chantal
ladesou qui nous a fait un festival la
semaine dernière alors on va démarrer
par titoff mon chéri le jour toumane je
suis fait d'alpha cette émission c'est
chaud il ya deux minutes a fait patrick
timsit
[Applaudissements]
apparemment il a des secrets d'histoire
je peux terminer mon imitation jonathan
coe a fini ses fans dans ces cracks à le
crack à tefana jetons soit passée à
chanter c'était comment manier son jet
privé patrick timsit chantal série le
ballon s'est jamais cru mais j'ai une
chance de gagner
[Applaudissements]
et comme ça pendant deux heures truc là
j'aime bien car en plus d'un talent on
va rentrer à tout à l'heure sur les
bateaux d'imitation suivante laurent
baffie géniale idée à michel boujenah
jean-pierre beaucoup je le sens pas du
tout ce je ne sens pas du tout michel
non je le sens pas non plus vas-y c'est
une sacrée soirée
[Applaudissements]
tu veux que je passais johnny laura pas
d'héritage pour david toi
[Applaudissements]
légalement ses gardes jouer c'est pas
mal à une prochaine série si lara fabian
à ce patrick sébastien tu essaies de te
rattraper
reem kherici lara fabian est ce que je
peux changer de chanteuse bah vas-y tu
veux faire quoi
céline dion céline jours qu aline les
freins cette vie donc je capote darren
avec fois oui fameux situes tu avais
c'est lara fabian
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un que vous savez faire voilà
c'est yan tu fais ce que tu veux toi tu
te fais les enchaînements sont formés
sur la photo car à mon directeur du cfr
chez ma soeur
certes on craint de faire toi qu ici
[Rires]
je suis
ben ali et en aval alors je sais pas le
faire je profite à tous j'ai mis très
bien christophe maé basique est faux
[Applaudissements]
c'est christophe khaled yade tue pas
nous faire geneviève de fontenay
comme je suis tellement content d'être
aux côtés de messieurs je te raconter
une blague si tu peux avoir du mal et
geneviève oui oui là le jour c'est
complètement et si j'étais mal j'étais
main j'ai envie d'aller à l'église pour
confesser gérant le curry ville monsieur
le curé je crois en rien du tout mais je
vais me confesser quand même genre lève
mon chapeau tu te dis pas l'effort qu'il
faut pour moi d'enlever mon chat qu'il
n'y a rien de chaud il reste aux deux
cailloux mais bon alors je rendrai xj
monsieur le curé je voudrais vous dire
un truc je voudrais vous confesser que
vous avez fait quelque chose de mal je
vais où il roule alors oui oui vous
savez pendant la guerre j'ai caché un
juif dans la cave aux usa c'est un acte
héroïque madame de fontenay ou devait
être fier de ça vous est ce qu'on
appelle une juste oui oui au fait je
demander de l'argent tu es moins j'ai
demandé l'équivalent de 500 euros par
mois à peu près eux mais oui mais ça
c'est formidable vous allez aller au
paradis madame de fontenay c'est
formidable et l'a donc elle lui dit le
problème c'est que j'ai toujours dit que
la guerre était finie
[Applaudissements]
je pense qu'une fois de plus cette
semaine en corse et liane foly kagame
[Applaudissements]